Hi, I'm Chris Banes, an engineer
on the Android
Developer Relations Team.
I'm here today to give you
an introduction to
ActionBarCompat.
So, what is ActionBarCompat?
Well, it's a support library
that was released this week as
part of the support library
version 18 which allows you to
add a compatible Action Bar to
your application, that allows
it to work from Android
2.1 upwards.
ActionBarCompat has been
designed to mimic the Action
Bar API, available in later
versions of the platform, as
much as possible, which
makes your job easier.
So how should you actually go
about adding it to your
application?
Well, there are two
ways we support.
First is via Gradle, and it's
been added to the Android
support repository, which means
it's a one-line change
to a build.gradle, as
you can see here.
Or, alternatively, you could add
it as a library project.
You should have a look at the
Support Library Release Notes
for more information
on both of these.
So, for the rest of
this DevByte, I'm
going to go for a scenario.
And that scenario is that you
have an application which
works on Ice Cream Sandwich and
above, but you want it to
work on devices from 2.1
and above instead.
The first thing we need to look
at are your resources,
specifically your menus
and your styles.
So ActionBarCompat includes
three styles which you must
use either directly
or indirectly.
And they are Theme.AppCompat,
Theme.AppCompat.Light, and
Theme.AppCompat.
Light.DarkActionBar.
Now the keen-eyed of you will
see that each of these mirror
a theme from Theme.Holo and
they act accordingly.
So back to our scenario, we are
in our manifest, we have
an activity which directly
uses the
Theme.Holo.Light.DarkActionBar
theme.
And this comes from the
Android system.
Now, to change this for
ActionBarCompat, we need to
use the theme from
ActionBarCompat instead.
So that would be the
Theme.AppCompat.
Light.DarkActionBar theme.
But most applications don't use
this, and they don't use
themes directly.
They have customized themes.
So here we have a small example
with a theme called
Theme.Styled, which has a parent
of Theme.Holo.Light
which has a custom
action bar theme.
And that style is referenced
below.
Now, for ActionBarCompat, we've
had to import a lot of
attributes into ActionBarCompat
which you have
to then use.
So there are two rules you
need to think about.
The first is that your style
must always have
an AppCompat parent.
And secondly, you must always
double-set each attribute,
once in the Android namespace,
and again
in the default namespace.
So back to our scenario.
Theme.Styled will become this.
So rule number one, has to have
an AppCompat parent, so
here we've changed it to a
Theme.AppCompat.Light.
And then rule number
two, you have to
double-set each attribute.
Now, we've already set it in the
Android namespace, as you
can see, so we just need to
copy that value and do it
again in the default namespace,
which is the second
bit in green.
That's it with styles.
As long as you follow those
rules, you should be fine.
So, following on with
that with menus.
So as with the standard action
bar, items are added to it via
the options menu.
And we recommend you add them
via menu resources.
So here is an example menu
resource, with one item, a
search item.
and that item has an
actionViewClass referencing a
SearchView.
Now the trouble with this is
that it has two attributes
which were added in Honeycomb,
so we can't use them before.
We can, but they'll
be ignored.
So to get around this, we've
imported all of the action
item related attributes
into ActionBarCompat.
So to do that, you
need to import
them into your namespace.
Now, we've called it the yourapp
namespace, but you
could call it anything
you want.
And the result is that for any
of the action item attributes,
you need to reference them from
this namespace, not the
Android namespace.
So that's it with
your resources.
Now we're going to move
on to some code.
So the first thing you need to
think about is your activity.
Your activities need to extend
from ActionBarActivity.
Now ActionBarActivity was added
in ActionBarCompat, and
it actually extends from
FragmentActivity itself.
That means you can continue
using Fragments, but you must
use the support implementation.
Then, as I mentioned earlier,
the API we've tried to add to
ActionBarCompat is very similar
to that of Activity in
later releases of Android.
So we have a getSupportActionBar
method,
which are will return you an
action bar, which has a near
identical API to .ActionBar
available in Honeycomb ICS.
So you can add tabs, change
navigation type, or change the
home item to act as
open navigation.
Another method you'll probably
use is startSupportActionMode,
which will start a contextual
action bar.
Now, as mentioned earlier, you
add items to your action bar
via the options menu.
So here is an implementation
that you would do in Android
version 1, where you override
onCreateOptionsMenu() and you
inflate a menu from
your resources.
Now, nothing has changed
from this.
It is exactly the same as you
do with ActionBarCompat.
The only difference is when
you want to start calling
methods, which were added in
Honeycomb or later, such as
getActionView we have here, to
get the actual reference to
the SearchView.
Now, to get around this in
ActionBarCompat, we've added
the MenuItemCompat class,
which is a collection of
static methods which will allow
you to reference these
methods cleanly and safely, much
like you do with a lot of
the other support methods.
Now we move onto fragments.
Now, nothing has changed
with fragments.
You can continue to use
android.support.v4.Fragment as
you always have.
And, indeed, to add items to
your options menu from there,
you just need to call
setHasOptionsMenu() during
your onCreate(), and then your
onCreateOptionsMenu() and
onPrepareOptionsMenu()
will be called.
And you inflate them just like
you do in your activity.
Hope this makes your
lives easier,
and thanks for watching.